It's okay, I'll take
attacks, but I'll never give up
I'm the theme of the beast
Until now, there
have been many times when we didn't understand each other But
still
, if you take it seriously, you'll be able to convey your thoughts It's weird
Irie-chan is
[music]
Why don't you run away I
told
you I just want to talk to you,
so I
can't understand that you were attacked just to gain
Sora's trust
Are you really human?  It's the same as humans
Yes, but not everyone is like that There are
good people among humans
I can't say for
sure but I want you to believe The
sky
won't deceive
[music]
Both of us  For some reason I can't look at it I
was told to leave it to you, but I'm nervous and
that's right.
In
addition
to helping the
townspeople, I'll also prove that I
'm a dragon.  When I said I was going to burn it, he
got really angry and that was a joke.
It's true, but
it's also a
strange cat and dragon tribe
[Music] Sora
met beings like you
for the first time
[Music] My
name is
Rain Shroud The
sky is the sky
Let's listen to the story for now